sprechen wir über diesen mann wohl
ottomeyer selensky der präsident der
ukraine er hat jetzt den us präsidenten
aufgefordert nicht bloß lieder amerikas
zu sein sondern der führer der freien
welt der anführer des friedens das war
der moment dort im us kongress
wir müssen darüber sprechen welche
konsequenzen daraus abzuleiten sind
welche hoffnungen sich die ukraine durch
diesen historischen moment hier sehen
sie den us-kongress sie sehen dort
zugeschaltet wo leute mir selensky
welche container auf die menschen stehen
auf applaudieren er hat eine feurige
rede dort gehalten hat brutale bilder
aus seinem land gezeigt hat ganz
konkrete forderungen hervorgebracht wie
ist das einzuordnen das fragen wir
direkt in kiew paul ronzheimer und sitzt
zugeschaltet schönen guten morgen paul
die rede von apollo domain selensky vor
dem us-kongress die hatte natürlich auch
direkte konsequenzen es gibt live
waffenlieferungen 500 millionen euro ein
großes paket dennoch es wurden nicht
alle forderungen immer wieder und wird
nicht müde zu betonen er braucht den
gesperrten luftraum über seinem land was
glaubst du wie sehr kann die ukraine wie
sehr kann seelands geht derzeit auf die
usa bauen
ich denke die ukraine können sehr auf
die usa bauen nicht was die
flugverbotszone über angeht sondern was
waffenlieferungen angeht und das ist
durchaus ein großes paket was joe biden
und andere dort geschnürt haben größe
auch als das was aus europäischen
ländern bislang gekommen ist die
flugverbotszone natürlich fordert
zielinski das immer wieder denn die
raketen regnen weiter runter hier auf
die städte sie töten zivilisten wir
haben erst gestern diesen angriff auf
das theater mario pohl gesehen auch hier
in der nacht in kiew hat es wieder
einschläge und explosionen gegeben wenn
auch nicht vergleichbar mit den
vergangenen tagen er sagt ganz klar ich
brauche diese flugverbotszone aber ich
bin sicher patricia er weiß am ende auch
dass er sie nicht bekommen wird und
dennoch wird er nicht müde zu betonen
dass er sie braucht denn das ist er sein
menschen seinen bürgern schuldig das ist
schon angesprochen diesen fürchterlichen
angriffe auf das theater von mario pohl
das war nicht bloß ein theater kann man
sich vorstellen diesen kriegszeiten
sondern das war ein schutzraum für wie
wir inzwischen wissen mehr als 1000
menschen dort die schutz gesucht haben
vor den bomben und raketen von putin und
die dann genau diese bekommen haben
putin offenbar gezielt angegriffen
diesen schutz nahm dieser zivilisten
frauen und kindern die dort sie schützen
wollten vor den bomben und raketen
putins wir sehen bilder von vorher von
diesem theater aus der luft
satellitenaufnahmen und wenn sie da
genau hinschauen wir gehen auch gleich
noch mal genauer an hier das gebäude von
oben satellitenaufnahmen denn dann sieht
man dort links und rechts buchstaben ins
gras geschrieben dort steht auf russisch
kinder dort also ganz klar die warnung
an putins truppen hier befinden sich
kinder die müssen wir schützen und diese
bitte hat er wieder mal gezielt muss man
ja schon sagen er ignoriert obwohl von
russischer seite paul weiteren daran
festgehalten wird dass man keine zivilen
ziele treffen will dass man nur
militärische ziele treffen will
dieses vorgehen von wladimir putin der
russischen armee das erinnert doch sehr
an den syrien krieg oder auch an den
tschetschenien krieg ende der 90er jahre
man will die menschen hier terrorisieren
man will zivilisten ganz gezielt töten
um diesen widerstand zu brechen auch den
psychologischen widerstand den es in der
ukraine gibt und das löst man natürlich
mit solchen angriffen aus insbesondere
dann wenn es gegen die schwächsten in
einer gesellschaft geht gegen kinder
gegen frauen gegen die die sich nicht
wehren können und man muss davon
ausgehen vertritt ja dass das
tatsächlich genau das ziel ist von
wladimir putin wenn die russin russland
behauptet dass man nur militärische
ziele angreifen dann ist das das habe
ich bereits mehrfach gesagt eine
grausame zynische lüge jetzt haben wir
den vergangenen tagen darüber berichtet
paul dass vielerorts die bürgermeister
einfach beseitigt werden da werden dann
ja statthalter eingesetzt von putins
gnaden und das ist vorübergehend auch
passiert in milito pohl dieser großstadt
in der ukraine der bürgermeister das
sehen sie auf diesen bildern der
überwachungskamera dort entführt in
diesen momenten die aufnahme oben rechts
am rand passiert dass bürgermeister
fedora wird sozusagen von der straße
weggeschnappt und verschwindet dann für
mehrere tage das ist er der mann der
bürgermeister der stadt milito pohl
fedorov wie man für doris und jetzt ist
ivan verlor ruf aber zurück und es gibt
ein beeindruckendes ein bewegendes
telefonat der ukrainische präsidenten
mit ihm vor wenigen stunden
hören wir einmal reine dieses telefonat
versuchen diese momente aufzugreifen in
denen die beiden sich wieder begrüßen
guten abend herr präsident guten abend
sagt zielinski dann wie geht es dir und
dann sagt der bürgermeister fedorov
erstmal jahr geht natürlich besser in
diesen momenten wo er wieder frei ist
ich freue mich dass du wieder da bist
gut zu hören du hörst dich auch gut an
sagt zielinski dann und der
bürgermeister fedorov bedankt sich dann
in diesen worten danke herr präsident
dass sie mich nicht zurückgelassen nicht
vergessen haben ja klar wir lassen
unsere leute doch nicht im stich sagte
lenzen und der bürgermeister für doro
verführt von den russen jetzt wieder
frei sagt ich werde ein bis zwei tage
brauchen und wieder fit zu sein danach
werde ich sofort in euer team
zurückkehren damit unser tag des siegels
mia kommt milito pohl sagt der soll
wieder zurück in das ukrainische land
und von den besetzern befreit werden die
mich festgenommen hat und der präsident
sei lenski der fingern an zu scherzen
und sagt ja ja klar 100% wir versprechen
dir nicht die jetzt zwei tage frei zu
geben du bist ja noch jung und ich denke
es reicht vielleicht auch ein tag um
wieder dabei zu sein dann lassen sich
die beiden noch am ende über die russen
aus beschimpfen ein bisschen fedorov und
zehn ends gesagt nein das sind nicht so
meine worte die ich nutze aber im grunde
stimme ich dir schon zu also irgendwie
ein telefonat dass eine seltsame
normalität transportiert in diesem jahr
wirren irren und so gefährlichen
kriegstagen paul
ja und auch eine unglaubliche
emotionalität und
der ukrainische präsident und sein team
begreift es eben auch diese einzufangen
allein die kamera wie man dort selensky
eben mit seinem smartphone sieht auch
dass wieder ein zeichen ein zeichen dass
man es anders hier macht in der ukraine
als in russland jeden tag aufs neue
beweist man das und dann dieses
telefonat was für viele ja auch ein
symbol ist der hoffnung ein mann der
bekannt wurde dadurch muss man sagen
dass er von den russen mit einer tüte
über den kopf entführt wurde der jetzt
wieder da ist offenbar so heißt es gab
es eine art gefangenenaustausch mehrere
russische soldaten gegen diesen
bürgermeister aber das ist natürlich
wahnsinnig wichtig auch für die
bevölkerung zu sehen dass sich der
präsident dass sich die regierung um die
menschen die für die ukrainische flagge
kämpfen die auch als bürgermeister dort
stehen und ihre städte verteidigen
wollen dass man die nicht allein lässt
paul du weißt gestern auch bei uns in
der sendung zu gast zugeschaltet aus
kiew in der sendung für die nach acht
dort auch gas der ukrainische
botschafter hier in deutschland andrej
melik der erneut gefordert hat olaf
scholz möge jetzt nach kiew reisen
vorbild die drei eu chefs die das
gestern getan haben auch eine bitte die
im gespräch von dir mit den
klitschko-brüdern laut wurde die bitte
darum schaut euch das hier gerne an es
ist gefährlich aber noch viel
gefährlicher ist es passiv zu bleiben
nichts zu tun
hauptsache dass die entscheidung fällt
das der deutsche regierungschef auch mal
diese frage zeigt und vielleicht auch
die worte benutzte jemand hier in berlin
im jahre 1948 gehört hat schaut auf
diese stadt diese stadt sie ist bedroht
tag und nacht wieder geschossen
sie wird vergewaltigt jeden tag und
trotzdem steht diese start und ich
glaube wie man nach kiew gelangt das ist
eine andere sache am besten du dich mit
deutscher bahn bis zur grenze und dann
gibt es auch ukrainische bahn
wir haben immer noch das anders sein
dagegen wirklich sehr bequem reisen eine
faszinierende idee sagst du in dem
moment noch paul und du hast selber
heute bei twitter auch geäußert wie wäre
es wenn gerhard schröder zum beispiel
auf den mai dann reist und sich dahin
stellt dann wird sei ein lupenreiner
demokraten freund in dem moment
wahrscheinlich kiew nicht bombardieren
also auch das irgendwie ein naiver aber
richtig gute idee zurück zu dem was man
ihr gesagt hat jetzt kann der kanzler
ihr antworten gleich im bundestag ist es
soweit dort wird der ukrainische
präsident zugeschaltet sein zielinski
und da kann scholz direkt reagieren muss
er das deiner meinung nach
ich glaube nicht dass sich der
bundeskanzler da in irgendeiner form
treiben lässt wenn er das vorhat dann
wird er das plan ich glaube dass er sich
so wie ich olaf scholz einschätze da
eher zurückhält nicht weil er angst hat
sondern weil er womöglich glaubt dass
das das ist ja die lehre sozusagen der
spd seit vielen jahren putin irgendwie
provozieren könnte wenn er jetzt nach er
führe und das sozusagen dann die
verhandlungen wieder schwierig macht
also da so schätze ich sehr olaf scholz
einen der das dann so oft durch denkt
dass er dann zum ergebnis kommt dass das
keine gute idee ist ich glaube er wird
da heute nicht drum antworten auf diese
bitte des italienischen botschafters und
man muss ja sagen nicht nur des
ukrainischen botschaft dass sondern auch
des polnischen ministerpräsidenten heute
in bild und dem interview dass hans jörg
vehlewald geführt hatte hat ja auch
gesagt mensch oder schockiert dass wir
eine gute idee ich glaube er wird
versuchen zu betonen wie groß die
solidarität deutschlands ist mit der
ukraine wird betonen wie sehr man die
sanktion zumindest bestand jetzt mit
macht und auch erweitert und wie man an
der seite der ukraine stehe allerdings
muss man sagen gibt es da aus der
ukraine viele fragezeichen es gibt viele
probleme die diskutiert worden sind
zuletzt eben der ausfall des spd
staatssekretärs der da auf den
botschafter losgegangen ist vorüber wie
gestern gesprochen haben dass also das
werden sie hier alles gleich live bei
bild live sehen dann der ukraine präsent
selensky er vor dem bundestag paul
ronzheimer von cynthia vielen herzlichen
dank tieren